i got a bunch of notes here that i
wanted to kind of like you know work
through with you so um
i just wanted to start with nick lachey
um i heard you called him a little [ __ ]
at one point
more than once actually but yeah
yeah nick lachey you know it's just peak
hypocritical
you know
like
media i guess is what i would yeah he's
like a hollywood puppet was the
impression that i got his wife probably
runs him i wouldn't be surprised if
there's some pegging going on
god yeah yeah
maybe maybe i wouldn't be surprised
either
uh i mean
let's just start with you know
uh him and his his current wife so
they they wanted to put me on blast for
having preferences when
um
in reality they met on the set of a
music video
so
you know not exactly
the most uh you know deep way to meet
somebody like they saw each other
they're like oh this person's hot and
they they move i don't i don't know who
uh vanessa is
is she an artist or was she just like a
random dancing girl on the music video i
think she was a dancing girl on the
music video i mean she
she has a career now
yeah it was one of his videos i mean i i
wouldn't say that she was like a nobody
dancing you know she's she has her own
talents i don't want to take away from
take away from her skills and talents
but
there's there's no doubt that physical
attraction played an enormous role in
the relationship right and and so it
does for everybody exactly exactly
exactly but then let's back it up a
little bit
um nick lachey
and his ex-wife jessica simpson now the
really interesting thing about this is
unlike most marriages a lot of this
marriage was
was taped right it was you know on that
show
and let me just say that show did not
age well
it did not age well at all like if you
go back and watch clips of it and some
of them have surfaced kind of since all
this started to me
the dick like he's a huge dictor
um
and so it's just very again hypocritical
for him to tell me
uh anything about how it is i treat
women because
i mean like go look in the mirror bro
like go go watch some old tapes
yeah that's um
do you know what the phrase white
knighting means
yeah i've heard yeah yeah like it like
it seems like he and a lot of the other
guys on the show like a lot of your
co-contestants or you know
co-participants whatever you want to
call them we're doing a lot of white
knighting you know especially around the
women um and it was designed essentially
to
because i mean like you were essentially
the alpha male in the room right and and
everybody
was trying to reduce your status and
your value by trying to take you down a
notch by saying oh he's i don't know
he's degrading or he's harsh you know
there's different language that i heard
use like did you get the sense when you
were dealing with them especially during
the reunion part yeah absolutely um
you know i'll say it like this i mean
they it almost seemed like they were
upset
that i wasn't
like
bending the knee down
yeah bending the knee there you go
that's that's the perfect way to put it
yeah um
i'm like i'm not gonna do that like i'm
not gonna i'm not gonna like pretend to
be all sad and apologetic when
truth be told there isn't really
anything terrible that i did
um and that actually
made them mad you know in a lot of ways
but but not it was it was really ironic
because
before before that like even shane and i
shared an uber to the airport and flew
to l.a and everything it's when the
cameras came on
it's only then did they feel comfortable
to like kind of lay into me like that
but after that happened you know now
there is no relationship off camera
right but before that there was a
relationship
off-camera i mean we were we were
hanging out
not so long before that you know we
talked about the super bowl uh maybe a
month before
that we were um at
danielle's parents lake house and i was
there with nick and jared nyana and like
it was a great time natalie was there
too and then uh
i had visited shane to to go to the
bears packers game i visited him in
green bay and like stayed with his mom
and it was an awesome time
it's it's just when
i don't know it's like they took their
chance to be like all right we got to
make sure we don't associate with this
guy because he he won't like you said
perfect bend the knee and they didn't
want to associate with me so why do you
take that approach when it comes to
dealing with people i mean it's it's you
know it's generally only when you've got
options that guys are able to like sort
of live their life that way i think for
the most part a lot of guys today are
a lot softer than our parents generation
and you know there's these coin terms
like you know white knighting and soyboy
and there's a lot of guys that will just
like
do
do anything to make a girl look good at
their expense it's like guys will become
less so she can become more sort of
thing and your approach was like no um i
am who i am i have the preferences that
i have
if you don't like it then that's your
problem that might right how did you how
did you arrive at that like
was it like your upbringing is it part
of culture for you or
yeah hard to say hard to say and you
know
it's not as though i was unwilling
completely
to you know
try and protect or help the image of of
my ex-fiance either i mean
a good example of that is
i knew pretty early on that this this
wasn't going to work out
and i'm not going to say too much but
like let's just put it this way the
wedding was going to happen one way or
another you know but just let's just
kind of
leave it there you know
it had to happen for the show read
between the lines yeah okay um
and
she knew pretty early on that it just
wasn't it wasn't gonna be
it wasn't gonna it was gonna be a no for
me dog you know what i mean
but
i did
want to give her every opportunity to
you know leave this show with some
dignity self-respect whatever so i said
please if you get if you get asked first
it's probably best that you say no first
you know because i don't want to put you
in a situation
you know i'm i'm gonna
say no and then you know it we're gonna
be that it looks worse if i say no right
so so i kind of did that for her not to
minimize myself but just really just to
protect her
um and i feel like it almost like you
know what they say no good deed goes
unpunished like now it's kind of like
taking on a whole new thing
yeah i think you would have been an even
bigger villain if you were the one that
said no first hey guys i really hope
that you enjoyed that short clip if you
did consider supporting the creation of
content by checking out my supplement
line pinned in the top comment below of
this video in the comments there's a
link to the unplugged alpha dot com
forward slash shop when you click
through you'll be able to land over here
and the entire lineup is broken down by
category that it performs best in
estrogen metabolism fat burning your
foundational essentials for health
immune health performance and
testosterone support if you check out
with coupon code alpha 10 you'll get 10
off on your first order there's also the
option to use the subscribe and save
model or regular shipments will be sent
over to you on a regular basis and that
gives you a little bit of a discount and
your supplement facts are always broken
down over here thanks for watching i
hope you guys have an awesome day and
again check out that link it's pinned in
the top comment below in this video
peace out
you